[Music]
i'm gonna make a fried ice cream tasty
video i've never made fried ice cream
before so i'm going to test it three
different ways and then i'm just gonna
pick one to film is this going to work i
think as long as you insulate ice cream
with something i think it should work
so i'm laying out a piece of puff pastry
i'm rolling out the dough not too thin
that it doesn't insulate the ice cream
but thin enough that it cooks oh god
i didn't flour the roller all right i
messed that one up
nope
we're testing we're going with the tests
it's never perfect okay this is ready
this is ready to wrap i'm gonna lay the
ice cream in the middle and wrap the
puff pastry over the ice cream and then
crimp the sides like i would ravioli
what i want to do here is make sure the
ice cream is protected so that it
doesn't leak out i'm going to put that
in the freezer until it's hard we have a
lid here in case there's a fire because
you don't want to put oil fires out with
water you just put the lid on top and
back away you ready yep let's do this
it's looking pretty good oh i'm gonna
take it out golden brown look at that
should we taste this now yeah well i
guess i'll do it ah the ice cream has
melted it looks pretty tasty the ice
cream needs to be colder puff pastry
needs to be thinner so it cooks faster
it's pretty good the taste is fantastic
but in terms of beauty shot that's
useless
so i'm gonna take the ice cream balls
soak it in an egg and vanilla mixture
put that in panko freeze it and then
when that's hard and ready repeat the
process freeze it again and then fry
it okay that was fast oh wow look at
that so quick gonna break into it really
okay
it's maintained it's shape and it's got
a nice crust here i like the crunch but
panko is one flavor so if we do
different kind of crust probably tastes
better
[Music]
i'm laying this pound cake on this cling
film and then i'm putting the ice cream
on top of the pound cake so it's
insulated now i'm gonna wrap it into
this ball shape so it looks like that
and freeze it when that's fully frozen
i'll take that out and dip it in tempura
batter once i dip that in tempura batter
i'm going to deep fry it and that will
be tempura fried ice cream all right
should we break into it
wow look at that all right it's ice
creamy ice cream has managed to stay
intact it's almost like ice cream cake
if you want to fry ice cream this is
probably the best way temporary one all
right i'm gonna film the tempura one
[Music]
yes keep going come on i just gotta lift
it
i think that's a good one yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you